so liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
würden gerne anfangen
liebe Kolleginnen liebe Kollegen
herzlich willkommen in der
Bundespressekonferenz wir setzen die
Pressekonferenzen zur Bundestagswahl
fort jetzt geht es um das Abschneiden
der Grünen unter zu begrüße ich ganz
herzlich die beiden Vorsitzenden
Annalena baerbock und Robert Habeck ein
herzliches Willkommen an sie
und da die Pressekonferenz auf mehreren
Kanälen live übertragen wird noch mal
kurz der Hinweis die
Bundespressekonferenz ist keine
Institution der Bundesregierung sondern
ein unabhängiger Verein von Journalistin
im Journalisten die aus Berlin über die
Bundespolitik berichten und unsere
Aufgabe ist das Pressekonferenzen zu
veranstalten damit unsere Mitgliedschaft
umfassend sich umfassend informieren
kann das als Vorbemerkung und jetzt hat
das Wort Frau bärbock
ja schönen guten Tag auch von unserer
Seite jetzt wo das vorläufige
Endergebnis vorliegt freuen wir uns dass
wir 16 Direktmandate gewonnen haben was
gestern Abend noch nicht so klar war
klar jetzt auch dass die SPD stärkste
Kraft ist herzlichen Glückwunsch von uns
an dieser Stelle an die Sozialdemokraten
wir haben einen klaren Auftrag von den
Wählerinnen und WLAN bekommen für ein
Aufbruch in unserem Land zu sorgen auch
wenn das Ergebnis deutlich hinter dem
zurückliegt was wir erwartet und für was
wir gekämpft haben jetzt eine Erneuerung
dieses Landes anzugehen und deutlich zu
machen dass wir nicht nur
schrittchenweise Vorankommen müssen
sondern dass wir wirklich eine
Erneuerung brauchen in der Infrastruktur
in der Digitalisierung unseres Landes
und dass die Klimapolitik
querschnittspolitik einer nächsten
Bundesregierung sein muss das bedeutet
nicht nur im umweltresort verankert
sondern sich durchzieht durch die
Wirtschafts- und Industriepolitik die
Verkehrspolitik die Landwirtschaft
dieser Politik weil die Frage der
Klimaneutralität die Zukunftsaufgabe
unserer Gesellschaft und damit auch die
Zukunft für den Wohlstand in unserem
Land ist auf dieser Grundlage werden wir
jetzt gemeinsam Robert Habeck und ich
als Parteivorsitzende Gespräche mit den
anderen Parteien führen haben wir
gestern Abend ja auch schon mal deutlich
gemacht dass das so ist dass wir vor
allem viel auch im geschützten Raum auch
mit kleineren Parteien Gespräche führen
werden um diesen Auftrag den die
Wählerinnen und Wähler uns gegeben haben
für eine echte Erneuerung jetzt in
Deutschland zu sorgen gestärkt in die
nächsten Wochen zu gehen
mit dem Wahlabend bricht tatsächlich
eine neue Zeitrechnung in Deutschland an
wenn es nicht und ich glaube dann werden
alle Leute wirklich kirre werden noch
mal eine neue Auflage einer sogenannten
früher genannten großen Koalitionen
geben soll wird es einen dreiparteien
Bündnis geben das ist auf der
Bundesebene nicht geübt und man muss
vielleicht auch sagen im Wahlkampf nicht
wirklich vorbereitet worden der
Wahlkampf hatte seine eigenen Logiken
Turbulenzen Irrungen und Wirrungen aber
das aus dem Wahlkampf heraus ein klares
Mandat und eine klare Richtung für
Energie umgegeben würde das kann man
glaube ich nicht behaupten gleichwohl
muss natürlich wie immer die Regierung
dann aussieht sie wird einer klaren
politischen Vorstellung einer
politischen Identität mit einem
politischen Plan sofort ans Werk gehen
dafür sind die Herausforderungen einfach
zu groß und zu dominant als das ist dann
eine Politik des kleinsten gemeinsamen
Nenners des ewigen Kompromisses des
suchen es nach unten immer nur geben
kann das ist natürlich vor allem
angesichts der globalen Erderwärmung und
der schlechten Bilanz Deutschlands
co2-mission einzusparen die
vordringlichste Aufgabe da im
klimaschutzfortschritte zu erzielen aber
auch Demografie und Rente sind wichtige
Themen die liegen geblieben sind Europa
Einwanderung Fachkräftemangel und Flucht
in einem System zu bringen die
Außenpolitik gerade nach dem Debakel in
Afghanistan neu zu durchdenken neu zu
eichen Europa nach zögerlichen und nur
in der corona-pandemie gegangenen
Schritten wieder auf einen Kurs der
Integration zu bringen und das kann
eigentlich immer nur passieren wenn
Deutschland im Zusammenspiel mit
Frankreich entschiedene Schritte geht
den sozialen Zusammenhalt
hochzuhalten in Zeiten der Zumutungen
die ohne Frage die ökologische
Transformation auch bereithält dafür zu
sorgen dass die Gesellschaft nicht
auseinanderfällt das sind dringliche
Aufgaben das setzt voraus dass die
bundesregierungsparteien sich der Größe
der Aufgaben klar werden wir haben vor
dem Wahlkampf und auch während des
Wahlkampfs uns auf diese Zeit
vorbereitet und unabhängig von dem
Wahlergebnis ergibt sich eine
Notwendigkeit einfach aus den
Verhältnissen dass wir unseren Beitrag
leisten und ich würde sagen stark und
vielleicht auch vor allem wir unseren
Beitrag leisten dass diese Regierung aus
dem Gebirge der letzten Wochen und
Monate heraus zu einem zu einer
Regierung für das Land und für den
Menschen wird die das Vertrauen dass
dann mit dem Beileid sicher
materialisiert hat auch würdig ist und
das ist eine anspruchsvolle Aufgabe und
auf die konzentrieren wir uns jetzt mit
voller Kraft
herzlichen Dank dann kommen wir zu
fragen und die erste hat Herr Krämer
haben sie Mikrofon man hört sich
schlecht
nachdem sich heute morgen beraten haben
sieht das sondierungs-team der Grünen
aus wie viele Leute sind da drin
und zweite Frage wäre was sind die roten
Linien der Grünen in Sondierungen es
gibt es überhaupt nicht
ja wir haben uns heute morgen als
Bundesvorstand beraten natürlich auch
wie man in Sondierungen geht aber das
noch nicht mit allen Gremien geklärt
deswegen können wir heute dazu zu dieser
Uhrzeit auch noch nichts auf der
Bundespressekonferenz sagen und mit
Blick auf die roten Linien wir haben
Sondierungsgespräch hier noch nicht mal
angefangen wir haben in diesem Wahlkampf
immer deutlich gemacht dass es ein
Aufbruch braucht dass es nach diesen
Jahren wo Deutschland wirklich schlecht
regiert worden ist gerade mit Blick auf
Zukunftsaufgaben dass das diese große
Aufgabe für das nächste Jahrzehnt ist
Deutschland klimaneutral zu machen auf
den Pfad des Pariser Klimaabkommens zu
bringen und dafür für neuen Wohlstand
und vor allen Dingen eine klimagerechte
Gesellschaft zu sorgen
die nächste Frage Herr Jung
habe sie kennen ihre Partei besser als
als ich kann man einer Partei durch also
beibringen mit einer Partei die zweites
ins Ziel gekommen ist zusammen zu
arbeiten
aus all dem was wir gesagt haben wird
davor dass die Materialität der
Koalition entscheidend ist da wo am
meisten
Klimaschutz beziehungsweise Antworten
für die großen Herausforderungen der
Zeit gegeben werden da sollte die
Regierung hingehen also dass man da
ergibt sich aus der Sache herausfinde
ich aber natürlich ist das Wählervotum
ernstzunehmen hat es angesprochen oder
zumindestens angedeutet dass ich über
die Nacht ja deutlich
herauskristallisiert hat dass die SPD
vorne liegt wir haben jetzt das
vorläufige amtliche Endergebnis und
daraus ergibt sich natürlich ein Pre der
Gespräche mit der SPD und der FDP
das heißt es ist unwahrscheinlich dass
sie ihre Partei überhaupt vorschlagen
könnten
Union zusammenzuarbeiten das kann man
nicht sagen es werden ja Gespräche
geführt und die sind ernst zu nehmen und
ernst zu nehmen heißt halt dafür zu
sorgen dass die Regierung entsteht die
einem entschlossensten ist entlang der
Punkte die wir genannt haben anders sind
denkbar die größten Fortschritte zu
erzielen wir werden sehen was dabei
rauskommt aber sicherlich und auch mit
Blick auf die letzten Stunden wo die
Union ja gerade selber dabei ist sich
aus der Regierungsfähigkeit ein Stück
weit zu verabschieden gibt es eine
gewisse Logik die Gespräche mit SPD und
FDP
jetzt zu führen das heißt aber nicht
dass wir mit der Union nicht reden
werden
die nächste Frage Frau Sawicki
guten Tag Rebecca Sawicki von Watson
Frau beerbox sie sind mit dem Anspruch
dem Wahlkampf gegangen kannst daran zu
werden das hat ja jetzt nicht geklappt
trotzdem haben die Grünen das beste
Ergebnis seit jeher eingefahren sehen
Sie sich jetzt als königsmacherin und
wenn ja
würden sie zur Not eine
Regierungsbildung platzen lassen wenn zu
wenige ihrer Themen bei SPD oder Union
oder FDP Anklang finden würden
wir haben klaren gesellschaftlichen
Auftrag weil das haben die letzten
Monate ja deutlich gemacht wie stark
dieses Land eine Sehnsucht nach einer
wirklichen Erneuerung hat und vor allen
Dingen die großen Zukunftsaufgaben der
Modernisierung unseres Landes endlich
anzugehen und das ist das wofür wir
angetreten sind auch wenn wir unser
Wahlergebnis und Wahlziel nicht erreicht
haben ist das der Auftrag für den wir
gewählt worden sind so wie angesprochen
haben mit unseren besten Ergebnis jemals
jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass Deutschland
auf den Weg der Klimaneutralität kommt
und das gute ist ja an den Gesprächen
dass das nicht nur eine grüne Forderung
ist sondern dass das seit sechs Jahren
Aufgabe dieser Bundesregierung ist und
deswegen muss es Grundlage für die
nächste Bundesregierung sein diesen Pfad
der Klimaneutralität jetzt gemeinsam
einzuschlagen haben wir im Übrigen
jedenfalls rhetorisch auch alle
Kandidaten in diesem Wahlkampf deutlich
gemacht dass sie das zumindest versuchen
wollen
dass ich die nächste Frage Herr Müller
ja Holger Mühle wohne Generalanzeiger
Frau Werbung ich würde gerne wissen ob
dieser Wahlkampf ihr Verhältnis
zueinander verändert hat und von ihnen
möchte noch gerne wissen Frau berbeck ob
sie Herr Lindner gestern mit dem Angebot
überrascht hat
das erst Grüne und FDP miteinander
sprechen oder ob Sie ein solches Angebot
umgekehrt auch vor gehabt hätten
ein Wahlkampf um das Kanzleramt
verändert die
Rollenbeschreibung bzw die Rollen
Ausübung das ist ja offensichtlich und
logisch sonst würde man das ja gar nicht
machen aber das persönliche Verhältnis
ist gut stabil im Takt und
vertrauensvoll wie ihr und je und in
dieser Zeit die jetzt ja über den
Wahlkampf hinausreicht wo wir alle die
Parteien aber eben wir auch vor der
Verantwortung stehen dem Land eine
stabile und
gut zusammenarbeiten und an den Aufgaben
der Zeit wachsende Regierung zu geben
kann man sich darauf verlassen dass
unser Verhältnis einen Anker und
Stabilitätsfaktor sein wird
nach diesem Wahlkampf überrascht mich
gar nichts mehr und erst recht keine
Einladung zu Gesprächen bzw es haben wir
vorher selber gesagt dass wir natürlich
nicht darauf warten bis Leute uns
anrufen sondern dass wir auch in
Gespräche gehen weil die Situation halt
eine andere ist wie bei anderen
Bundestagswahlen es gibt jetzt keine
Partei die irgendwie bei 35 Prozent
liegt und sagen da guckt den ein ruf ich
mal an und solange könnt ihr warten
sondern dass Partei nach untereinander
Gespräche führen das haben wir ja von
Anfang an klar und deutlich gesagt
Teil ihres Plans gewesen dass die
umgekehrt auf die FDP zugegangen wären
wenn sie Lindner gestern nicht gemacht
hätte
wissen sie das Wichtige ist ja gerade in
so einer Phase da haben wir auch alle
Erfahrungen von den letzten Jamaika also
Sondierungen dass das unklügste ist dass
man Wortprotokolle über das was man sagt
tut anruft irgendwie minütlich rausgibt
deswegen Gespräche vielleicht auch schon
für die nächsten Tage können Sie gerne
nachfragen aber mit wem man wann wo
telefoniert oder spricht das werden wir
vertrauliche behandeln unterhalten
dann habe ich als nächsten Frage stelle
rin Frau Kollegin hier vorne
vielen Dank an Herrn Harbeck die Frage
die sich eigentlich
dass die personelle Aufstellung der
Grünen jetzt verändert zwischen ihnen
beiden sind sie jetzt das neue
Machtzentrum der Partei treten sie
sozusagen nach vorne in die erste Reihe
wenn Sie die koalitionsverhandlung als
sozusagen entscheidende Person und sind
sie auch derjenige der der künftige
Vizekanzler sein wird
wir finden die Verhandlung gemeinsam als
gewählte Bundesvorsitzende
Punkt und alle weiteren Fragen sind
ebenfalls geklärt
Fragen sind geklärt und in welcher Weise
das gehört ja zu der Verantwortung die
wir jetzt hier mehrfach betont haben
dass man gut vorbereitet und geklärt
reingeht so wie sie das von uns kennen
und es gehört aber auch zur
Verantwortung diese Klärung dann nicht
zu Markte zu tragen aber gehen Sie davon
aus dass wir komplett sortiert sind
die nächste
so wie wir hier sitzen
wir sitzen jetzt beide parteivorsitze
das haben wir vor Monaten genauso
besprochen dass wir wenn der Wahlkampf
vorbei ist wir gemeinsam als
Parteivorsitzende diese Sondierung
führen und auch alle sonstigen Fragen
bei uns selbstverständlich geklärt
worden sind weil das gehört zu einer
Verantwortung dazu wenn man ein Land
führen will
dann hat mich Frau Herzog auf meiner
Liste
haben eben gesagt der Wahlkampf habe
deutlich gemacht dass es eine Sehnsucht
nach Erneuerung gebe
woraus leiten Sie das ab und haben die
immer noch nicht ganz verstanden haben
sie die Frage jetzt geklärt wer von
ihnen Vize Panzer oder Kanzlerin würde
in einer Regierung und sie wollen nur
nicht darüber sprechen
oder ist es eine offene Frage
zuerst die Frage wir waren ja in über
100 Orten unterwegs auf Marktplätzen
aber auch an Schulen an
nachbarschaftszäunen wo in jedem
Gespräch deutlich geworden ist dass
viele Menschen nicht mehr verstehen
können dass all das was eigentlich
möglich ist nicht nur klimaneutral zu
werden sondern auch in Kitas in Schulen
in Krankenhäusern dass das nicht
angepackt wird und dieser Wunsch nach
Erneuerung der ist wahnsinnig groß wir
haben und das ist das was uns Schmerz
diese Dynamik nicht in Wählerinnen und
Wählerstimmen umsetzen können dass wir
in der Regierung anführen aber das
bedeutet ja nicht dass
satt sein vom Status Quo vom
wegducken irgendwie verflogen ist
sondern die Menschen in diesem Land
wollen besser regiert werden und das ist
unsere Verantwortung und unser Anspruch
dass jetzt in die nächste
Bundesregierung mit einzubringen und das
ist der Auftrag von dem ich vorhin
gesprochen habe auch wenn wir das jetzt
in anderer Rolle sind als wir das
ursprünglich geplant haben und ja das
was wir jetzt beide deutlich gesagt
haben bei uns sind die Fragen geklärt
aber wir sind jetzt ein Tag nach einer
Bundestagswahl wir fangen jetzt an
Sondierungen zu führen gemeinsam im Team
als Parteivorsitzende gemeinsam mit
einem sondierungsteam was wir die
nächsten Tage verkünden werden und alle
weiteren Personalfragen kommen dann zu
ihrer Zeit
sprechen Sie parallel mit SPD und
Klang jetzt eben ein bisschen so also
FDP ist ja bekannt aber parallel
ich gehe davon aus wir gehen davon aus
dass es jetzt in den nächsten Tagen
Gesprächen mit allen Parteien geben wird
die potenziell in der Lage sind eine
Regierung in den verschiedenen
Konstellationen zu bilden
und die wird es geben und dann werden
auch irgendwann sichtbare Sondierungen
anfangen
online fragt Ulrich Schulte von der taz
wann treffen Sie sich mit Christian
Lindner
probieren dann
fragt er noch ganz grob was müsste diese
in diese vorab Sondierung sich ergeben
das was wir hier mehrfach betont haben
das womit wir angetreten sind nicht eine
kleine spiegelstrichliste sondern ein
wirklicher Aufbruch für dieses Land eine
gemeinsame Erzählung wie man Deutschland
modernisieren kann das ist ja nichts was
man im Finger schnips macht sondern das
ist die gesellschaftspolitische Aufgabe
die auch zu einigen Umbrüchen führen
wird in einer Gesellschaft das heißt es
ist nicht nur vier Jahre angelegt
sondern es ist auf das nächste Jahrzehnt
angelegt diese Modernisierung
Deutschlands voranzubringen und zwar im
wahnsinnig schnellen Tempo die deutsche
Industrie auf den Weg zur
Klimaneutralität zu führen und dafür
gleichzeitig nicht nur die Arbeitsplätze
zu sichern sondern die Frage von
Gerechtigkeit und Wohlstand neu zu
definieren und das ist das was natürlich
die zentrale Aufgabe ist für die ersten
Gespräche in Sondierung da zu schauen
mit wem kriegt man ein solches
gemeinsames Bild am besten hin
dann die nächste Frage Herr Decker
ja erstmal die Frage an Sie beide kommt
es für Sie in Betracht Herr Laschet zum
Bundeskanzler zu wählen unabhängig davon
wie stark die Union ist weil ja doch das
allgemeine Urteil innerhalb der Union
aber auch außerhalb der Union vor allem
natürlich lautet dass das Problem Herr
Laschet als Person auch ist und deswegen
die Frage an Sie ist es für sie
vorstellbar in zum Kanzler zu wählen
wenn denn die Verhandlungen so etwas
nahelegen würden
die zweite Frage an Sie ja habe die
FDP scheint in sie besondere Erwartungen
zu setzen jedenfalls ist das der
Eindruck den man aus der Pressekonferenz
mit Herrn Lindner mitnehmen kann aber
auch aus Gesprächen die inoffizielle
stattfinden können Sie das scheint auch
mit der Erfahrung Schleswig-Holstein
zusammen
zusammenzuhängen können Sie dazu ein
paar Worte sagen wie sich ihr Verhältnis
zur FDP darstellt
also
zur ersten Frage
Herr Laschet hat ja im Wahlkampf
ein paar Probleme gehabt das ist
natürlich uns auch nicht
entgangen auf der anderen Seite ist das
fehlervotum zu respektieren und das
heißt eben auch dass einem in einer für
die Republik
9 und so noch nicht da gewesenen
Situationen die man tatsächlich als
ihrer Übergang beschreiben kann auch
nicht nur die naheliegendste Option das
ist die Ampel die SPD hat die Nase vorn
die wissen dass die Grünen und die SPD
eine geschichtliche Vergangenheit haben
bei allen Problemen die es gab dass man
nicht nur diese Option sondiert und
miteinander redet sondern eben die
anderen auch das gebietet der Respekt
finde ich vor dem Votum der Wählerinnen
und der Wähler es geht jetzt erstmal
darum in einer Phase wo sich Deutschland
neu aufstellt alle Möglichkeiten
auszuloten Erweiterung der Möglichkeiten
das ist das Gebot der Stunde und dann
so sind ja Sondierungen zu führen wenn
man in zwei verschiedenen
Konstellationen sondiert dann sollte die
Regierung
entstehen die die Möglichkeiten gemessen
an den Verhältnissen unserer Zeit am
besten nützt dass wir da eine gewisse
Voreinstellung haben eine gewisse vor
Erwartung dass ich ihn jetzt nicht
entgangen denke ich
aber zu sagen wir ignorieren alles
weitere würde ohne Not den politischen
Raum eng machen und da sind wir jetzt
nicht wir brauchen eine weitere des
politischen Raumes und das gilt abstrakt
so mit das schließt allerdings natürlich
mit ein dass die Parteien mit denen man
dann redet auch überhaupt handlungs- und
regierungsfähig sind und deswegen wird
man sich genau anschauen müssen was in
der Union da gerade passiert
gerade in so einer Konstellation müssen
sich die führenden Akteure zutrauen und
auch darauf verlassen können dass die
Prokura im eigenen Laden haben wenn das
in Zweifel steht dann machen irgendwann
Gespräche auch keinen Sinn mehr mehr
kann ich dazu nicht sagen zu den
Personen
gezielt es sich finde ich nicht dann
urteile zu geben der Wahlkampf ist
vorbei und so wenig wie wir uns von
anderen rein reden lassen wollen mit wem
wir bei Sondierung Verhandlungen und mit
welchen personalauflaufen so sehr will
ich das auch oder wollen wir das auch
gegenüber anderen nicht als Hochmut zur
schaut tragen das ist die Sache der
Parteien jeweils selbst
und was das Verhältnis zur FDP angeht
glaube ich verrate ich kein Geheimnis
dass die Grünen und die FDP in geübter
Gegnerschaft zueinander stehen bei den
Fragen von steuersozial
Wirtschaftspolitik bei den Fragen er
prinzipieller Natur welche Rolle hat der
Staat wie frei sollen die Marktkräfte
sein wie hoch oder stark sollen die
Leitplanken für den Markt sein da
treffen Welten aufeinander nun ist aber
wenn man nicht und das glaube ich kann
man Deutschland nicht noch mal zumuten
davon ausgeht dass schwarz-rot noch
einmal eine Chance hat davon auszugehen
dass in welcher Konstellation auch immer
und das spricht eben einiges dafür dass
es dann die Ampel wird davon auszugehen
dass Grüne und FDP zusammen regieren
werden dabei ist die Maus ja nun mal
kein Faden ab klar wir hätten uns auch
eine Regierung mit der SPD und grün
vorstellen können aber ist so nicht
gekommen sondern müssen wir zusammen
regieren und macht es sehr Sinn erst
einmal darüber nachzudenken ob
diejenigen die denkbar weit voneinander
politisch entfernt sind irgendwie
ankommen können eine Brücke finden eine
Gemeinsamkeit gemeinsame Projekte die
man vielleicht gar nicht sieht wenn man
immer nur auf das Trennende geschaut hat
und das ist so in Schleswig-Holstein
passiert in der Tat gab es für mich
schon mal eine Art ähnliche Situation
2017 nur etwas anderer Vorzeichen damals
war ja schon eine Regierung mit Grünen
und SPD im Amt und jetzt die Mehrheit
verloren also man kann es nicht genau
gleich
parallelisieren aber in der Tat wurden
Ampel und Jamaika parallel sondiert und
auf einmal mussten Grüne und FDP
miteinander reden und das hatte da
vielleicht eine eher geübte Tradition
dass man schon mal ein paar Kanäle
gelegt hat insofern ist das alles nicht
exakt gleich vergleichbar aber
eine Idee wie so ein Bündnis Leben
bekommen kann und aus einem
Gebirge und gestolpere heraus vielleicht
eine eigene Identität finden kann die
gibt es schon und das ist das hat nur
was mit professionellen Umgang zu tun
denke ich dass man jetzt versteht dass
der Wahlkampf vorbei ist und die
Verhältnisse nun so sind wie sie sind
und da muss man eben das Beste draus
machen und das Beste draus machen kann
das zeigen ja sowohl die ampelregierung
in Rheinland-Pfalz wie auch dieser Marke
Regierung in Schleswig-Holstein bei all
den jeweiligen Problemen die es gibt
eben auch zu einer guten Regierung
führen und die muss jetzt gebaut werden
dazu passt die Frage von Hans Jessen in
der Pandemie haben wir eine Rückkehr des
Staates erlebt wie soll eine
Zusammenarbeit mit einer FDP erfolgen
die ja eher ein konträres
Staatsverständnis als die Grünen hat
ja das vor allen Dingen in dem Bereich
eine gesprochen hat also wenn man die
alte Ideologie Markt und Staat die sich
insbesondere ja bei Fragen von Umwelt
und Wirtschaftspolitik ausdrückt da muss
man natürlich deutlich machen die
schaffen wir die Ziele die wir brauchen
nämlich Klimaneutralität mit Mitteln die
nicht in diesen alten Lagern verharren
sondern durch Investitionen in
Innovation angetrieben ist und zugleich
und das ist ja Aufgabe von Politik einen
klaren ordnungspolitischen Rahmen setzen
aber gerade im Bereich von
bürgerinnenrechten von der Frage was
bedeutet eigentlich ein modernes
Einwanderungsland im Jahr 2021 gibt es
zahlreiche Schnittmengen die wir auch
zwischen grünen und Liberalen haben und
das ist auch eine Kraft für eine neue
Regierung wo wir einen neuen Aufbruch
schaffen können nach 16 Jahren CDU
geführter Regierung in diesem Land dass
die gesellschaftspolitischen Fragen
nicht mehr auf der Höhe der Zeit sind
und wir auch hier wir in diesem Bereich
einen neuen Aufbruch schaffen können wo
gerade diese beiden Parteien auch eine
neuen Impuls setzen können auch gegen
die dritte Partei in diesem Bunde
sie haben gesagt klare Auftrag für
Veränderungen auf Nachfrage sagten sie
das haben sie aus Gesprächen im
Wahlkampf bekommen die das Wahlergebnis
ist der aber so dass die regierenden
Parteien eine Mehrheit haben also ist ja
können Sie erklären wo da der Auftrag
für die Veränderung ist und die zweite
Frage dass Dilemma wenn sie mit der CDU
zusammengehen ist das für ihre
Wählerschaft eine riesige Zumutung
umgekehrt bei der FDP wenn sie zu Scholz
geht ist es für deren Wählerschaft eine
riesige Zumutung sehen sie da
irgendeinen Ausweg aus diesem Dilemma
wie es wer weiß da in den sauren Apfel
wir wollen sie das den anderen
schmackhaft machen also ich sehe es
nicht vielleicht haben sie das
eigentlich Kolumbus danke
auf die erste Frage sieht man ja auch an
allen Befragungen die stattgefunden
haben was sind die wichtigsten Themen in
diesem Land was erwarten die Menschen
eigentlich von der neuen Bundesregierung
auch wenn uns leider all diese Menschen
nicht komplett gewählt haben sind die
Erwartungen klar und deutlich dass
Deutschland eine Modernisierung braucht
dass wir in diesem Land dafür sorgen
müssen dass die großen großen Fragen
auch der sozialen Gerechtigkeit das ist
eins der zentralen Themen weswegen
Menschen ihre Wahlentscheidung bei
dieser Wahl getroffen haben dass sie
angegangen werden gerade nach anderthalb
Jahren Pandemie und einer Partei die
genau dafür für diese Erneuerung
angetreten ist kommt bei so einer
Regierungsbildung eine entscheidende
Rolle zu ja so sehen wir unsere
Verantwortung als grüne auch wenn wir
uns erhofft und gewünscht hätten dass
ich das in den Stimmen auch noch etwas
deutlicher ausgetragen hätte
[Musik]
die Partei die
in klassischen Terminal gesprochen die
so meine Ansicht nach nicht mehr
existieren dass Lager wechseln muss hat
die größere Zumutung zu tragen es ist
völlig klar das kann ich aus eigener
Erfahrung berichten wir sind ja 2017
eine Jamaika-Koalition eingestiegen die
einen guten Koalitionsvertrag hatte ich
weiß aber dass ich auf dem Parteitag
gesagt habe kann sein dass wir jetzt
gerade eine Entscheidung treffen die uns
in den Abgrund führen wird und
vielleicht sind wir in fünf Jahren nicht
mehr da weil wir jetzt quasi das Lager
wechseln Anführungsstrichen ich glaube
nur dass diese lagerwelt nicht mehr die
Wirklichkeit repräsentiert so ist das
Land nicht mehr wir haben nicht mehr ein
linkes und ein rechtes Lager sondern es
gibt auf der Landesebene ja schon lange
zu besichtigen die kunterbuntesten
Formen von Bündnissen und die
Gesellschaft ist auch kunterbunter
geworden und die
politischen Einstellungen gegen quer
durch familienfreundschaften
Freundeskreise und Arbeitskollegin durch
einen gewissen Sinne holt ja Deutschland
gerade das nach was ich als
gesellschaftliche Veränderung in den
letzten 18 Jahren 20 Jahren ereignet hat
trotzdem ist natürlich die politische
Voreinstellung so wie sie gesagt haben
die Antwort kann ja nur sein dass jeder
Partei sich in dem Bündnis wiederfinden
muss also und deswegen haben wir gestern
Abend immer betont und das ist wichtig
zu verstehen dass Rot-Grün zwar eine
gewisse politische Nähe hat aber die
Ampeln nicht Rot-Grün plus ein bisschen
gelben Kit ist weil die Zahlen einfach
nicht reichen sondern eine Ampel und das
würde respektiv auch für Jamaika gelten
folgt einer komplett eigenen neuen Logik
jede Partei muss das Bündnis aus sich
selbst heraus tragen das zu verstehen
ist der erste Weg überhaupt dazu zu
kommen so ein Bündnis angehen zu können
schmieden zu können wenn man mit dem mit
der mit der Schere im Kopf losläuft es
gibt ein Lager und das hat jetzt nicht
ganz gereicht und jetzt muss die eine
Partei quasi den Verrat am anderen Lager
begehen dann kann man es auch gleich
sein lassen es muss was Neues entstehen
und dieses neue entstehen ist
kompliziert aber natürlich auch extrem
reizvoll es könnte schlimmere Antworten
in Deutschland geben als das was neu ist
entsteht in einer neuen Zeit als könnte
ja auch geradezu eine verfügungskraft
haben Politik attraktiv zu machen ist
eine harte Übung mit vielen zugungen
verbunden auch noch mal neu nachzudenken
wie Debatten Wahlkämpfe in der
Vergangenheit geführt wurden wie man in
der Vergangenheit schön doof fand und
mit dem man jetzt vielleicht oder mit
der man jetzt vielleicht über Jahre am
Kabinettstisch sitzen muss und dann muss
ich ja sofort die Einstellung ändern das
Kabinett selber muss ja auch eine
verschworene Gemeinschaft werden aber
hey es kann was Neues entstehen
Deutschland Hallo schlaft ihr noch es
können was Neues entstehen ist ja
eigentlich eine coole Situation also
vielleicht mit dem Spirit da reinzugehen
kann ja auch eine Energie freisetzen und
auf die setzen wir
Herr Kollege
Nightline Zeitung für kommunale
Wirtschaft ich hätte zwei inhaltliche
Fragen zum ein Frau perwort sie haben
darauf hingewiesen dass Klimaschutz ist
nicht Querschnittsaufgabe haben sie mir
schon klar dass sie jetzt in am Beginn
der Verhandlung stehen aber haben Sie
schon gewisse Vorstellungen über den
Zuschnitt von dem klimakministerium ob
das zumindest zum Beispiel Wirtschaft
und Energie aber noch vielleicht auch
noch was anderes enthalten sollte und
dann noch eine Frage an haha Beck
einerseits geht es ja jetzt die
Herausforderung sie müssen eine
Regierung bilden die gut sein soll
andererseits haben wir ja den Zeitdruck
zum Beispiel sie kennen ja die
Forderungen nach diversen 100 Tage
Programmen für Ausbau erneuerbare
Energien dann steht es fit vor 55 Paket
LED jetzt ja an zu weiteren
Entscheidungen in nächster Zeit also
sozusagen haben sie sich das selber so
ein bisschen eine Deadline gesetzt bis
wann eine neue Regierung stehen sollte
im ersten Teil Ihrer Frage ja das muss
der Querschnitt der gesamten Regierung
sein aber wie wir vorhin schon auch bei
anderen Fragen gesagt haben jetzt stehen
erstmal die Gespräche an jetzt steht
erstmal an diese neue Erzählung die
dieses Land braucht gemeinsamen
Eckpfeilern zu verankern klar ist nur es
wird keinen neuen Aufbruch in
Deutschland geben wenn weiterhin das
Umweltministerium ging das
Wirtschaftsministerium arbeitet und sagt
die einen machen Klimaschutz in die
anderen machen Wirtschaftspolitik wir
wissen dass die Zukunft der Wirtschaft
klimaneutral sein muss und deswegen muss
das
zusammengeführt sein und nicht
gegeneinander in einer Politik aber wer
dann welche Häuser besetzt und wie das
umstrukturiert wird das ist vollkommen
offen aber wir haben in
Baden-Württemberg ja eine Blaupause
dafür wie eben die Frage von moderner
Industrie- und Wirtschaftspolitik
aussehen kann im Zusammenspiel mit einem
klimaneutralitätsfahrt der dann aber von
der gesamten Regierung auch getragen
werden muss weil ansonsten wird man
diesen krisengroßen Herausforderungen
nicht gerecht werden
Weihnachten
also
Kollege mit der nächsten Frage
vom Bayerischen Rundfunk über ihr
Verhältnis der FDP hatten sie schon
gesprochen wie es denn ihr persönliches
Verhältnis zu Christian Lindner
du bist dran
so wie zu allen
charmant
charmant ist besser ja
hart manchmal
dann die nächste Frage hier vorne Frau
Kolleginnen
vom Spiegel ich wollte einmal fragen wer
übernimmt den Verantwortung für dieses
Wahlergebnis was ja doch wirklich weiter
hinter zurückliegt was sie wollten gibt
es da personelle Verantwortung die da
übernommen wird und kann sie noch eine
überraschende Gemeinsamkeit uns erzählen
die sie mit der eine überraschende
Gemeinsamkeit die Sie vielleicht mit der
FDP haben abseits von Digitalisierung
Bürgerrecht und Cannabis
also Christian Lindner und ich sind
beide ziemlich gleich alt vielleicht
nicht überraschend aber ist eine
Schnittmenge Robert Habeck und Christian
Lindner sind beides Männer ist auch
nicht so überraschend Schnittmenge und
wahrscheinlich essen wir alle drei gerne
Eis
also das ist ja so in allen Gesprächen
dass man miteinander zum einen immer
sehen muss dass man ehrlich und offen
reden kann ansonsten kann man Gespräche
nicht sinnvoll führen und deswegen ist
für uns auch so wichtig dass wir das
vertrauensvoll führen weil sonst ist es
schon von Anfang an zum Scheitern
verurteilt mit Blick auf die Frage
unseres wahlergebniss natürlich tragen
weder für die Verantwortung ich war
Kanzlerkandidatin will beide sind
Parteivorsitzende ich noch meiner gesamt
ganz besonderen
verantwortungsrolle und wir werden das
gemeinsam als Partei jetzt auch
analysieren aber wir haben genauso eine
Verantwortung dass wir jetzt eben in
diesem Gesprächen deutlich machen dass
es zu einer Veränderung kommt das haben
jetzt schon 20 mal gesagt aber das ist
unser Auftrag zugleich als
Parteivorsitzende diese Partei jetzt in
eine Bundesregierung zu führen die ein
neues Zeitalter einleitet
und
auf es ist ja interessant dass sie sagen
sie haben alle personellen
Entscheidungen getroffen aber sie wollen
sie uns nicht mitteilen das heißt ja
auch dass ihre sondierungspartner nicht
wissen wer jetzt die Verhandlung führt
als mögliche Vizekanzler Vizekanzlerin
wann wollen Sie uns denn mitteilen wer
diesen wichtigen Kosten in der Republik
übernehmen soll sollten Sie koalieren
mit entweder Union oder SPD ja das haben
wir zu Anfang ja dieser
bundesprässponden und zwar gesagt Robert
Habeck und Annalena baerbock als
Parteivorsitzende führen diese
Verhandlung und das wissen auch Herr
Scholz Herr Lindner und Herr Laschet
dann habe ich auf meiner Liste Hand
Grimm
ja Christian Grimm von der Augsburger
ich wollte von Ihnen beiden wissen wie
sie eigentlich einen zentralen
Unterschied zur FDP überbrücken wollen
der bei den Staatsfinanzen liegt also
die Grünen wollen die Investitionen in
den Klimaschutz über Schulden
finanzieren die FDP will das nicht oder
sehr viel weniger wie kann das gelingen
dass das zusammen geht dass man den
Klimaschutz eben trotzdem gestemmt und
finanziert bekommt das ist sicherlich
eine der trennenden Positionierung aus
dem Wahlkampf heraus völlig klar
Objektiv ist es so dass Geld aufgebracht
werden muss die deutsche Wirtschaft
alleine das ist noch nicht die
öffentliche Hand die öffentliche
Infrastruktur also Schulen Kitas Gebäude
Bahnlinien sondern nur das was die
private Wirtschaft die deutsche
Industrie investieren muss zur
Klimaneutralität beziffert die Summe auf
zwei Billionen Euro das natürlich eine
grobe Schätzung da muss man sich mal
klar machen worüber wir reden es 500 mit
100 Milliarden mehr oder weniger sein
das sind echt gigantische Summen und sie
selber sagen um das auszulösen diese
Investitionen auszulösen braucht es
ungefähr zehn fünfzehn Prozent
öffentliche Sicherheiten Kredite bzw
Fördermaßnahmen und die privaten Banken
sagen das können wir nicht stemmen das
ist ein da ist zu viel Ausfallrisiko
also stehen wir eigentlich von der
Situation wo entweder das Geld
aufgebracht wird durch Sicherheiten die
der Staat gibt oder es wird nicht
aufgebracht mit der Konsequenz das
entweder die Klimaneutralität nicht
hergestellt wird dann scheitert die
Regierung
das muss man sich klar machen dann
passiert es eben nicht oder es passiert
an anderer Stelle der Welt und dann sind
die Arbeitsplätze fortsch das Problem
ist objektiv da wir haben einen
Vorschlag gemacht wie man das lösen kann
indem wir die
Schuldenbremse zeitgemäß reformieren das
denke ich dürfte jetzt in diesem Raum
klar sein wir wollen sie überhaupt nicht
abschaffen auch ausweich ausweichen ist
das falsche Wort wir wollen nur das
verändern was sie auf dem privaten
Bereich kennen wenn Sie sich eine
Immobilie kaufen ist es auch ein wert
auch wenn Sie sich dafür verschulden und
das Haus kostet 300.000 Euro sie haben
die 300.000 Euro ja als Haus stehen das
Geld ist ja nicht weg nur in der
politischen Diskussion sind die ist der
öffentliche Besitz nicht quantifiziert
und deswegen verkauft er auch in
Deutschland und sind die kommunalen
Schulden so hoch nur für den Aufbau
dieses öffentlichen Vermögens wollten
wir die oder wollen wir die
Schuldenbremse reformieren so dass man
das was an öffentlichen Werten dauerhaft
geschaffen wird gegenrechnen kann gegen
die Kredite wie man nimmt im Grunde wie
im privaten und das schließt aber auch
natürlich Infrastruktur in der
Wirtschaft mit ein wenn man das nicht
will und ich würde die Hoffnung noch
nicht aufgeben dass man versteht dass
das eine in sich schlüssige gute ja ich
würde fast sagen konservative
wertkonservative Logik ist das müssen
sie mal nur übertragen auf dem privaten
Bereich was das bedeuten würde wenn man
das nicht tun redet man würde quasi gar
keinen Besitz
erwerben oder nur wenn man das Geld
dafür hat dann würden die weite Bereiche
des privaten Wirtschaft würden sofort
kollabieren also ich glaube es gibt eine
gute Hoffnung der FDP oder der Union zu
erklären was der Gedanke dahinter ist
und dass das Festhalten in einer
falschen Ideologie nicht zur Zeit passt
wenn das aber nicht gelingt muss die
Gegenseite erklären wo das Geld
herkommen soll also das Problem ist ja
Objektiv da da teuer wird das jetzt in
den nächsten Jahren wird das teuer
irgendjemand was Geld investieren und
dann kann man natürlich sagen jeder tut
es selbst also die Unternehmen müssen
das Geld selber aufbringen müssen sich
selber verschulden jede Privatperson
muss ich selber Verschulden die
Vermieter sanieren die Häuser und dann
geben sie das Geld an die Mieter weiter
dann kriegen wir echt ein Problem in
Deutschland nämlich an soziales Problem
auch wahrscheinlich ein ökonomisches
Problem weil einfach die Investitionen
ausbleiben die Wachstumsschwäche die wir
vor Corona hatten ja dann noch
kassierender ist oder wir investieren
über die Gemeinsamkeit und die
Gemeinsamkeiten einer Demokratie halt
über die staatlichen Möglichkeiten
hergestellt scheint uns eindeutig der
schlauere Weg zu sein wenn man nicht den
schlaueren Weg den besseren Weg den
pragmatischeren Weg gehen will denke ich
ist die
argumentationspflicht der anderen Seite
zu sagen wie es dann gehen soll am Ende
geht es nicht darum den einen Weg
durchzusetzen sondern das Ziel zu
erreichen das ist und das muss auch
erreicht werden sonst
haben wir in einer zentralen Frage schon
mal uns das erste Bein gestellt in der
neuen Regierung wir werden dann in
Forschung in wirtschaftlichem Aufschwung
in Prosperität und in Klimaschutz immer
weiter zurückfallen
und eine Regierung die von sich aus weiß
dass sie weiter zurückfällt die sollte
vielleicht mal überlegen ob sie auf die
richtige Regierung ist also da wird noch
ein bisschen drüber zu reden sein aber
mich würde sagen die Argumente wie eben
kurz umrissen sind eindeutig auf unserer
Seite
denn Frau Kollegin
aber frei vom Tagesspiegel ich würde
gerne wissen ob sie seit gestern Abend
schon immer mit Armin Laschet auch
telefoniert haben und wenn ja ob er
ihnen einen konkretes Angebot gemacht
hat und wenn ja was
zu wenig wie wir über die Telefonate mit
anderen Herren sprechen wir auch nicht
über solche Fragen öffentlich
dann Frau tut bitte
sie haben vorhin die Demografie als
liegengebliebenes Thema genannt die
Demografie ihrer Wählerinnen und Wähler
unterscheidet sich ja sehr stark von der
zunehmenden rentnerinpartei SPD und auch
CDU ist das ein gemeinsames Projekt mit
der FDP und wir können immer das
vielleicht vermitteln wir sind für die
jungen da die haben uns
überdurchschnittlich gewählt
das Problem ist ebenfalls Objektiv die
Vorsorge fürs Alter
könnte stabiler aufgestellt sein und in
der Tat gibt es da ich würde fast sagen
überraschenderweise jedenfalls im
Wahlkampf häufig übersehenderweise eine
Parität zwischen der FDP und uns wir
sind beide der Meinung dass man über ein
öffentlichen Fonds den wir bürgerformen
wie sie die FDP nennen weiß ich gar
nicht genau aber es ist angelehnt an dem
steht an dem schwedischen formmodell
versuchen die dritte Säule anders zu
organisieren als ich derzeit ist also
nicht mehr über Riester Verträge und die
private Wirtschaft sondern beim Staat
einen vorn zu schaffen der dann die
Rente stabilisiert der Unterschied und
der ist natürlich gravierend ist das ist
bei uns zusätzlich zur
gesetzlichen Altersvorsorge ist also die
wird dadurch nicht geschwächt sondern
das riestersystem die Riesterrente die
wird abgeschafft und überwunden und die
FDP so muss man es verstehen will die
Gelder die dort reingehen in diesem
Fonds aus der gesetzlichen
Rentenfinanzierung rausziehen das
wiederum halten wir für falsch bzw auch
nicht für ökonomisch richtig aber wir
fangen ja erst an mit den Gesprächen
also beide Parteien haben einen
Interesse einen neuen dritten Weg neu zu
beschreiben einen neuen Fonds aufzulegen
und dann muss man mal drüber reden aber
in der Tat sind das jedenfalls Ansätze
die Rentenpolitik
neu zu eichen und was neues
hinzubekommen in Deutschland
Herr Kollege mit der nächsten Frage
ja Gerald trafiker vom Spiegel und Frau
Berber herrbeck wie groß ist ihre
Befürchtung dass es doch eine groko
geben könnte wo die SPD durchaus
dominanter sein könnte als in einer
Ampel
naja es würde all dem widersprechen was
gerade von Seiten der SPD im Wahlkampf
deutlich gemacht worden ist und wenn man
vielleicht minütlich gerade mitbekommt
was in der CDU oder in der Union los ist
halte ich das nicht für einen
wahrscheinlicher Szenario
es wäre das Gegenteil von dem was wir
jetzt ja glaube ich auch in den letzten
45 Minuten deutlich gemacht haben wie
eigentlich die Stimmung und Situation in
diesem Land ist die lechts nach einem
wirklichen Erneuerung gerade nach acht
Jahren großer Koalition
ja genau so ich glaube der erste der
dann steige ich das Markus Söder
ich sehe das nicht also außer alle
stellen sich so doof an dass am Ende
wieder
kein Dreier Bündnis zustande kommen aber
dann haben wir wirklich etwas falsch
gemacht ansonsten halte ich das für
nahezu ausgeschlossen
denn habe ich als nächsten Fragesteller
Herr Gabriel ist ne ganz hinten
für den Deutschlandfunk zwei Fragen die
erste an den Habeck warum wäre Herr
Lindner ein guter Finanzminister und
vielleicht auch an sie beide wie schade
finden sie es eigentlich dass die Linke
so schlecht abgeschnitten hat und somit
ja eine Koalitionsoption weniger zur
Verfügung steht
mit der Frage an uns beiden an
persönlich habe ich alles Mitleid für
Wahlkämpferinnen und Wahlkämpfer die
Hoffnung hatten und nicht in den
Bundestag gekommen sind das ist ja weiß
jeder immer mit hohem persönlichen
zeitlichen Einsatz verbunden manchmal
auch finanziellen Einsatz verbunden und
viele Leute jetzt in Deutschland haben
ein halbes Jahr gerackert Familie
Freizeitsport Garten alles ist
vernachlässigt die Katze halb verhungert
und dann hat es nicht gereicht das ist
bitter und
alle wissen dass es passieren kann und
im Grunde muss man noch mal nachträglich
sagen wahnsinn wie viel Engagement und
politischen Ehrgeiz ist in diesem Land
gibt denn nur so kann das ja
funktionieren also das
persönliche Mitgefühl jetzt für die
Leute der Linken das habe ich wie auch
für alle anderen die auch bei uns
vielleicht gehofft haben in den
Bundestag zu kommen
politisches Mitgefühl habe ich wiederum
nicht ich finde das jede Partei am Ende
das Ergebnis tragen muss wie ist da ist
denn so funktioniert Demokratie machen
nur noch dann Angebot der Souverän
entscheidet darüber und dann kann man
nicht danach rumjammern dass der
Souverän falsch entscheiden hat
entschieden hat sondern da muss ich halt
die Linke in die eigene Nase fassen und
fragen was haben wir denn falsch gemacht
und wenn wir besser sein wollen was
machen wir das nächste Mal besser das
ist in dem Sinne eine ein Beruf den man
ausübt und wenn der nicht gut genug
ausgeübt wird dann liegt es nicht an den
Leuten die die Ware nicht annehmen oder
das Angebot nicht angehen sondern da hat
man das falsche Angebot gemacht
Christian Lindner
also ich würde nicht gerne spekulieren
über Posten das ist der gleiche Grund
den anderen
nicht am Anbeginn solcher Gespräche über
postenverteilung und personalverteilung
zu reden entscheidend ist dass auch sich
alle klar machen dass ich nehme jetzt
nur die ökologische Krise dass die Dinge
miteinander zusammenhängen und das ein
Denken in Sektoren nicht zeitgemäß ist
und dass die ökologische Transformation
und der Schutz des Klimas nicht nur eine
Frage der Energie oder der Industrie
oder der Verkehrspolitik ist sondern
alle Bereiche berührt vor allem würde
ich denken den sozialen Bereich das sind
Zumutungen die da kommen werden und wenn
das einhergeht mit einer Politik die
immer nur die gleichen profitieren lässt
und alle die Zumutung tragen noch mehr
aufgebürdet bekommen dann wird das alles
scheitern
es hat aber auch was viel mit der
Finanzpolitik zu tun und die
Finanzpolitik muss so wie wir eben neue
Fragen haben ebenfalls auf der Höhe der
Zeit sein wenn das gelingt dann ist es
eine gute Finanzpolitik und wenn es
nicht gelingt ist eine schlechte
Finanzpolitik danach sollten sich die
Gespräche richten und danach sollte dann
eine hoffentlich Einigung erfolgen und
dann gibt es die Ressort Zuständigkeiten
und dann die Personal Zuständigkeiten in
dieser Reihenfolge aber erstmal
verstehen was gerade Phase ist
live wird vom ZDF fragt Herr Habig sie
sind neu in den Bundestag gewählt welche
Aufgaben in der Fraktion wären für Sie
erstrebenswert
das stimmt ich freue mich sehr und vor
allem jetzt in meinem Fall ganz
persönlich freue ich mich dass ich in
einem sehr ländlichen Landkreis das
Direktmandat erzielen konnte und da habe
ich eine klare Vorstellung wie ich die
Verantwortung die ich jetzt ja
unmittelbar von den Wählerinnen und
Wählern dort gekommen habe ausüben kann
das ist häufig diskutiert und gut
vorbereitet also ich hoffe dich hörte
ein guter regional Abgeordneter der für
seinen Wahlkreis für den Norden eine
würdige Vertretung in Berlin darstellt
über weitergehende Rollen in der
Fraktion habe ich mir keine Gedanken
gemacht und das ahnen sie ja das
Annalena Gerber und ich gerade gut damit
beschäftigt sind Regierungsbeteiligung
vorzubereiten und nicht so viel Zeit
darüber verschwenden welche
Aufgaben wir darüber hinaus noch in der
Fraktion haben da wollen wir in der
Solidarität auch mit dem
Fraktionsvorstand
arbeitsteilig vorgehen
denn Herr Kollege
kriminalitätszeitung also während des
Wahlkampfes ich habe so verstanden dass
die wollen die Klimaneutralität
finanzieren durch die Bekämpfung der
Finanzkriminalität Sie haben gefunden
den Leuten die Geld verdienen außerhalb
des Finanzamts haben sie ungefähr so
gesagt und sie Frau Bernburg während des
Trails haben sie wollen auch vor
konsequente Bekämpfung der
Geldwäsche es gibt noch andere Sachen
zum Beispiel die Schwarzarbeit
Bekämpfung also die Leute von FKS
Finanzkontrolle Schwarzarbeit reden dass
sie arbeiten stichprobenmäßig ist viele
Milliarden
gehen verloren meine Frage wie schaffen
Sie das mit Herren Urlaub Schulz die
alle diese Fehler nicht sieht also meine
Zeitung ist kriminalitätszeitung ich war
bei ihm in Ministerium und der er kennt
sich nicht gut mit
Finanzkriminalität be geschweige denn
die finanzenskandale von cum-ex und so
wie schaffen Sie das mit den Urlaub
Schulz
gibt das haben wir wie sie ja gesagt
haben in den triellen Robert Harbecke
deutlich auch immer zuvor deutlich
gemacht und auch deswegen wollen wir in
dem Bereich einiges anders machen und
auch deswegen haben wir klar und
deutlich gesagt dass wir mit Blick auf
Haushalt und Finanzen in diese Sanierung
hat reingehen werden ich will jetzt
nicht unser ganzes Wahlprogramm an der
Stelle wiederholen aber gerade mit Blick
auf Kontrolle Schwarzarbeit mit
Aufstockung von Personal auch beim Zoll
ist es offensichtlich dass das
stichprobenartig in den Bereichen nicht
so weitergehen kann und es ist ja nicht
nur eine Frage von Finanz- und
Steuerpolitik sondern das ist ja auch
eine zutiefst arbeitsrechtliche Frage
das sehen wir auch in den
fleischereibetrieben im mit welchen
Arbeitsverträgen da gearbeitet wird dass
es auch eine kontrollfrage und deswegen
braucht es dort eine weitere Aufstockung
des Personals und das ist ja auch sehr
deutlich geworden vor allen Dingen vom
nächsten Finanzminister eine klare
Priorität auf die Bekämpfung von
Geldwäsche und auch mit Blick auf die
Frage von Steuerbetrug aber das Geld das
ist so das einmal klarzustellen ist
jetzt nicht wir wollen nicht Geldwäsche
bekämpfen und den Steuerbetrug bekämpfen
um die Klimafinanzierung voranzubringen
sondern ist ja eine zutiefst
gesellschaftliche Frage von
Gerechtigkeit wenn der Buchladen um die
Ecke vernünftig seine Steuern zahlt und
Großkonzerne mit
Deals die deutlich am deutschen Fiskus
sondern europäischen Solidarität
Vorbeigehen das umgeht und das eine hat
mit dem anderen nichts zu tun aber dass
da in Milliardenhöhe Gelder nicht im
deutschen Haushalt landen das ist ein
riesengroßes Problem für unser Land
zusätzlich also Jürgen Trittin hat heute
um 8 Uhr in der Morgenmagazin von 50
Milliarden jährlich Steuerhinterziehung
gehen und sie sie wissen das von ihrem
Kollegen sowieso aber wenn sie nicht das
Finanzministerium oder das
Arbeitsministerium in der Hand haben ich
glaube sie schaffen das nicht oder doch
ja die Zahl ist ungefähr richtig man
weiß es nicht es gibt auch Schätzungen
die höher sind das muss man sich mal
klar machen worüber wir reden also
möglicherweise wir reden ja über Gelder
das ist keine Steuererhöhungen sind
Gelder die eigentlich gezahlt werden
müssten die jede Summe der
Steuererhöhung über die wir uns im
Wahlkampf eingeschlagen haben x-fach
überschreitet also die höchste
Steuererhöhung die es in Deutschland
geben könnte wäre das die Steuern
gezahlt werden die eigentlich gezahlt
werden müssten dann wäre der Haushalt
ganz gut aufgestellt und da finde ich es
schwer an dagegen anzuargumentieren wenn
man dagegen an argumentiert dann kann
man eigentlich nur denken das könnte
eine Art Standortvorteil sein dass man
in diesem Land nicht
ehrlich sein muss na viel Spaß bei der
Argumentation also kommt nach
Deutschland hier könnt ihr Geld am
Fiskus vorbeibringen also das möchte ich
gerne mal öffentlich in der Diskussion
erleben und umgekehrt müsste es
vielleicht auch gerade
marktwirtschaftlern einleuchten das
Steuerhinterziehung ein Wettbewerbs eine
wettbewerbserziehung ist also der Markt
ist dann ja ungleich wenn man
gegenüber dem Wettbewerber ein Vorteil
hat wenn man sich
im Graubereich bewegt dann ist das ja
eine wettbewerbsversicherung von Viren
Marktbedingungen das müsste eigentlich
auch gestanden in Manchester Liberalen
einleuchten dass das nicht richtig sein
kann also es gibt kein Argument Fairness
wie Annalena baerbox sagt
Wettbewerbsgleichheit und
[Musik]
im Grunde nur schäbiger Argumentation
wenn man das verteidigt also das könnte
zum Beispiel das müsste wichtig sein
dass man vorne zu bringen
haben Sie eigene Fehler eingeräumt über
welchen ärgern Sie sich am meisten was
war der schwerwingste Fehler im
Wahlkampf als Kanzlerkandidatin und habe
kann man dem Verhandlungspartner
beibringen das Geld was künstliches ist
und CO2-Emissionen echt sind
Monaten schon rauf und runter diskutiert
dass ich mich sehr über Fehler geärgert
habe und jetzt geht es darum daraus zu
lernen und es in einem nächsten
Wahlkampf besser zu machen
da habe ich ja schon deutlich gesagt
dass ich ein Buch nicht noch mal
schreiben würde
nach dem Wahlkampf sitzt bei manchen
beim vielen Menschen noch mal einen eine
neue Nachdenklichkeit ein ich würde er
uns gar nicht rausnehmen wir können ja
auch Punkte noch mal neu überdenken und
die Argumente von anderen vielleicht
entspannter gewichten als in einer
zugespitzen öffentlich immer
hochgejtzten Situationen und deswegen
sind wir beide ganz hoffnungsvoll Dinge
dass Erkenntnis er zu gewinnen ist nach
dem Wahlkampf also die Antwort ist ja
die zweite war noch was offen
dann Frau Kollegin noch mal
genau ich wollte noch mal nachfragen die
haben ja vorhin gesagt dass die groko
sozusagen gegen das Gegenteil von dem
wer wäre was während des Wahlkampfs
versprochen wurde Frau Berber sie
standen aber auch im triell und haben zu
Herrn Laschet gesagt dass die CDU in die
Opposition gehört wäre es dann nicht
auch das Gegenteil von dem was sie im
Wahlkampf versprochen haben wenn sie
jetzt Jamaika anstreben würden ja wir
haben ja auch nicht gesagt dass heute
Jamaika anstreben sondern sehr sehr
deutlich gesagt mit wem wir jetzt
Gespräche führen
aber sie haben doch gesagt dass die auch
Gespräche mit der Union natürlich führen
wollen obwohl sie im Wahlkampf gesagt
haben dass sie die gerne in der
Opposition sehen
ja
das spricht jetzt dass du widerspricht
sich aber nicht gegenseitig wir werden
jetzt in Gespräche eintreten die SPD ist
stärkste Kraft geworden werden Gespräche
führen aber für uns ist Grundlage
zugleich dass wir deutlich machen dass
es in so einer Regierung neuen Aufbruch
gibt und wenn andere mit uns Gespräche
führen reden wir auch dafür weigern wir
uns Gesprächen nicht und das was man
kann ich mich nur wiederholen was wir
gerade erleben weiß ich nicht ob in der
Union jetzt in den nächsten Tagen
überhaupt noch so viele Gespräche
geführt werden
dann habe ich noch meinen Kollegen
leifert
haben sie eine Alternative zum
mitregieren und der fügt hinzu
vielleicht lieber gar nicht als schlecht
regieren
wir haben es glaube ich den Punkt
erreicht alles gesagt ist an der Stelle
wir Deutschland brauchen eine Regierung
logischerweise sonst wäre das ja eine
fast alles
wie Annalena baerbock wie ich jetzt
schon zwei dreimal gesagt habe glaube
ich das schlechteste wäre dass die große
Koalition man muss ja sagen die
ehemalige große Koalition noch mal noch
mal was nicht fünften Aufguss erfolgt
irgendwann wird diese Suppe wirklich
dünn und deswegen geht jetzt alles darum
in die Regierung zu kommen und ist auch
kein Geheimnis dass wir den Anspruch
haben wir haben uns darauf vorbereitet
wir glauben dass es nicht gut war dass
Deutschland seit 16 Jahren nicht mit von
den Grünen gestaltet wurde und deswegen
stellt sich die Frage von keiner
alternative nicht es geht darum dass
jetzt gängig zu machen
dann sind wir durch mit allen Fragen
eine hatte ich noch übersehen Frau
Herzog
Klimaschutz ein bisschen haben sie schon
angerissen da haben wir ja andere
Konzepte für mich
also wir haben ja
FDP die FDP setzt stark über eine
Steuerung auf eine Steuerung über den
CO2-Preis die setzen da auch stärker auf
Ordnungsrecht wie stellen Sie sich vor
dass sie das zusammenbringen können und
die Union plant eine schonungslose
Analyse des eigenen Wahlkampfs tun sie
das auch und in welcher Form und wann
also die Fragen hatten wir vorhin schon
mal mit Blick auf die Frage was ist das
Ziel und das Ziel ist Klimaneutralität
bis Mitte 2040 und dieses Ziel müssen
wir gemeinsam erreichen und wir haben so
wie Robert Habeck ist gerade vom
Finanzbereich deutlich gemacht haben im
Finanzbereich Vorschläge gemacht wie wir
die Investitionen die wir stemmen müssen
auch im Bereich von Klimaschutz aber
auch im Bereich von Infrastruktur wie
wir diese Investitionen stemmen können
um Deutschland zu modernisieren und das
gleiche gilt dass wir konkrete
Vorschläge gemacht haben wie wir auf den
Pfad der Klimaneutralität kommen können
und wenn die FDP jetzt noch andere
Vorschläge macht wie man auch dahin
kommt da muss man darüber sprechen was
ist der schnellste Weg was ist das
gemeinsame Mittel auf das man sich
verständigen kann aber das Ziel ist klar
diesem Ziel kann sich ja keiner
verweigern weil alle Parteien des
Pariser Klimaabkommen entsprechend mit
unterstützen ratifiziert haben auch wenn
damals die FDP nicht im Bundestag war
und das gilt es jetzt mit Blick auf
Ordnungsrecht mit Blick auf
Signale mit Blick auf
Innovationsförderung in Einklang zu
bringen um diese Ziele schnellstmöglich
zu erreichen und
es ist nicht mehr nur eine Frage des der
Klimapolitik sondern es ist die
essentielle Frage für den
Industriestandort Deutschland was ja
eigentlich auch eins der zentralen
Interessen von der FDP ist diesen
Industriestandort zu stärkern und damit
dem Wohlstand in unserem Land zu sichern
wie vorhin auch schon gesagt natürlich
werden wir auch in unserem Wahlkampf
reflektieren das jetzt aufs gleichsetzen
aber es sind verschiedene Prozesse
gleichzeitig die wir gerade angehen und
Haupt Priorität von uns beiden als
Parteivorsitzende ist jetzt die Grünen
in eine nächste Bundesregierung zu
führen
dann sind wir am Ende dieser
Pressekonferenz ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich für die Aufmerksamkeit